Herr Minister sie haben das Wort
liebe Frau Welti ich möchte mich
zunächst einmal erneut ganz herzlich
bedanken dafür dass wir hier in Ihren
Räumen durch ihre Gastfreundschaft über
die corona-pandemie und andere Themen
vortragen dürfen ich möchte mich auch
ganz herzlich dafür danken dass Frau
stockowski heute dabei ist und uns also
bei der Vorstellung der neuen Kampagne
gegen Corona unterstützen wird ein Muss
ich entschuldigen er war angekündigt er
ist krankheitsbedingt heute nicht in der
Lage zu dabei zu sein ich fange daher an
indem ich zunächst einmal darauf
hinweisen will neben den sehr
schwierigen Zeiten in sehr schwierigen
Zeiten der ukraine-krieg ist auf
absehbare Zeit nicht beendet wir leben
in Angst vor einer Ausdehnung des
Krieges selbst über einen möglichen
nuklear-schlag wird philosophiert zum
Teil in den Medien wir haben eine
gravierende Inflation zu bekämpfen
Energiepreise somit also wir leben in
der Zeit der großen gewesen und jetzt
kommt auch noch die kurve-pandemie
zurück sie war nie beendet und
erwartungsgemäß wird es jetzt eine
Herbst und eine winterwelle geben die
hat begonnen jetzt erstmal die gute
Nachricht wir haben es selbst in der
Hand ob diese große Krise noch einmal
die Bedeutung bekommt die sie gehabt hat
oder ob sie im Hintergrund bleiben kann
und wir werden alles daran setzen als
Bundesregierung dass die Krise die
kovid-krise im Hintergrund bleibt und
nicht an bestimmendes Thema wird dafür
werden wir heute eine Kampagne
vorstellen die sowohl das Impfen wie
aber auch den Schutz vor der Pandemie
betrifft und sie heißt daher auch
bezeichnend für das was sie auch ist wie
können wir uns schützen und die Kampagne
bedeutet oder wird genannt ich schütze
mich zunächst einmal wir sind gut
vorbereitet wir haben sehr gute
Impfstoffe wir haben zum ersten Mal seit
langer Zeit angepasste Impfstoffe die
genau auf die Variante passen die wir
haben die ba5 Variante die Impfstoffe
wirken daher ausgezeichnet es sind
Impfstoffe mit bekannten aber wenigen
Nebenwirkungen wir haben die Impfstoffe
also in der
Menge dass sie also zu jedem Zeitpunkt
in der Arztpraxis eine Hausarztpraxis
oder auch in Impfzentren abgeholt werden
können die Hausarzt arbeiten sehr eng
mit uns zusammen bei der Impfkampagne
wir haben die Impfstoffe auch in die
Pflegeeinrichtungen verbracht dort
laufen jetzt große also Impfkampagnen
somit die Impfung ist eigentlich
jederzeit möglich für jeden der sich
impfen lassen will zum zweiten wir haben
also gute Medikamente gegen covid
insbesondere paxovit zum dritten wir
haben eine sehr gute Übersicht über das
Infektionsgeschehen der Pandemie Radar
ist am Netz wir haben jetzt auch die
abwasserdaten am Netz wir sehen dass die
Parameter sich derzeit verschlechtern
aber wir können das sehr gut planen im
Moment und zum vierten wir haben ein
Infektionsschutzgesetz mit jetzt den
Ländern möglich ist für jeden Zeitpunkt
jetzt zusätzliche Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
zum Beispiel auch die maskenpflicht in
den Innenräumen zu vereinbaren somit
diese vier Elemente Impfstoffe
Medikamente
pandemerada und Infektionsschutzgesetz
mit diesen vier Maßnahmen wäre zu jedem
Zeitpunkt das Infektionsgeschehen ich
bringe hier nur ein Beispiel wenn jemand
jetzt drei Impfungen hat und geht über
zur vierten Impfung und ist über 60
Jahre alt dann reduziert er damit sein
Sterberisiko durch diese zusätzliche
Impfung noch einmal um 90 Prozent 90
Prozent sollte er trotzdem schwer
erkranken kann er durch die paxlovitgabe
das Risiko erneut um 80 bis 90 Prozent
senken das heißt wir haben tatsächlich
für die über 60-Jährigen hier die
Möglichkeit das Sterberisiko und das
Risiko sehr schwerer Teufel massiv zu
begrenzen dann bleibt nur noch ein ganz
kleines Restrisiko über das muss man
sich überlegen bei welcher anderen
Erkrankung haben wir das daher wollen
wir mit unserer Kampagne darauf also
hinweisen welche Möglichkeiten es geht
ich schütze mich so heißt die Kampagne
die haben wir vorbereitet in einer Art
und Weise dass es keine Angst Kampagne
es ist keine angstkampagne es sind
schwere Fälle zu sehen es sind
vermiedene Fälle zu sehen es sind
Menschen zu sehen denen es gut geht es
gibt Menschen zu sehen den also wieder
gut geht es gibt aber auch Menschen
denen es nicht gut geht denn wie zum
Beispiel jemand verloren haben oder die
nicht genug den ich vorher
zurückgekommen sind in das Leben was sie
vorher hatten wir haben in dieser
Kampagne ich schütze mich 84 echte
Personen die ihr Schicksal erläutern
oder ihre Gründe benennen weshalb sie
sich schützen wollen jeder tritt vor
jeder Mensch ist ich keine Schauspieler
keine Modelle niemand hat Geld bekommen
eine kleine Kostenpauschale vielleicht
100 Euro für Taxikosten oder ähnliches
das sind Menschen die aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft bereit sind über die
Kampagne zu sprechen die ihr Schicksal
vortragen viele dieser also Berichte
sind lustig sind reale Menschen sie
sprechen für die große Mehrheit in der
Bevölkerung es sind aber zum Teil
schwierige Schicksale und es geht auch
hier darum dass wir als Gemeinschaft
zusammenhalten ich will sagen was mich
besonders bestürzt hat in den letzten
Wochen wenn ich also über die also
Möglichkeiten eine herbstwelle
gesprochen habe oder was auch in Zukunft
sind zwei Dinge die mich immer besonders
betroffen haben das eine ist wenn ich
also vorgetragen habe dass die
Sterbezahlen wieder steigt
wir haben mehr Menschen die jetzt also
an kovic sterben da bin ich sofort
gefragt und ja wie alt sind denn diese
Leute wie alt sind die Leute wenn ich
das sage 75 80 Jahre Gottes Willen oder
als wenn es heißen würde das ist doch
dann sowieso ein alter was will man denn
da noch verlangen und das ist einfach
eine bestürzende Veränderung auch in
unserer Gesellschaft so haben wir zu
Beginn der Pandemie nicht gesprochen und
auch nicht gedacht dass man sagt alte
Menschen immer wieder wird da wird
nachgefragt sind die mit oder Anko wird
gestorben das ist oft nicht wirklich gut
unterscheidbar wenn jetzt manchmal
meinetwegen ein Mensch mit einer
Herzschwäche ins Krankenhaus kommt weil
er jetzt zusätzlich Wasser in der Lunge
hat weil er ankurveda krank ist dann und
dann an der Herzschwäche stört dann
stirbt er an der Herzschwäche aber wahr
ist wenn da die Kurve derkrankung nicht
bekommen hätte dann wäre möglicherweise
die Lungenentzündung auf der Grundlage
von Wasser in der Lunge nicht entstanden
und mir überlebt er hätte da noch
überlebt und dann werde ich aber immer
wieder gebeten so einer darf nicht
zählen der stirbt doch an der
Herzschwäche aber es ist nicht so er
hätte noch gelebt und wir wissen dass er
noch gelebt hat wir haben in deshalb
behandelt so hier das ist erste was mich
gestolz das zweite was mich bestürzt
also die vielen Opfer von lancowitive
haben das sind Menschen die sich an mich
wenden die haben da keine gute
Behandlung wir haben keine gute
Rehabilitation das sind Menschen die
dann zum Teil voll im Leben standen die
promoviert haben die einen tollen Beruf
gehabt haben die dann rausfallen und
dann plötzlich mit der Frage
konfrontiert werden ja wie haben Sie
schon mal über eine
Erwerbsminderungsrente nachgedacht das
ist die Frage die dann im Raum steht
oder dann wird gefragt ja also
wie stellen sich das denn selbst vor die
Leute sind ja plötzlich allein gelassen
und das sind ja ganz viele wir wissen
mittlerweile aus den Studien die es gibt
dass irgendwo zwischen fünf und zehn
Prozent der Menschen die Kurve bekommen
lohnkovic-symptome entwickeln die zum
Teil über viele Monate von dem was wir
wissen auch über ein Jahr nicht
weggegangen sind und aus der ersten saß
wenn der
202/2003 wissen wir dass diejenigen die
damals lonkovit bekommen haben zu einem
großen Teil auch nach 15 Jahren nicht
genießen waren es ist die Lage jetzt
eine bessere weil jetzt die Forschung
eine ganz andere ist als die
202/2003 das heißt wir werden da
tatsächlich eine deutlich bessere
Erforschung der Krankheit hinbekommen
und ich bin auch zuversichtlich dass wir
das hinbekommen aber auch diesen
Menschen wird diese Kampagne ich schütze
mich eine Stimme geben das ist eine
Stimme für die vernünftigen die immer
die pandemiekontrolle mitgemacht haben
das ist dezember für die älteren die
jetzt im Risiko stehen oder jemand
verloren haben das ist aber auch eine
Stimme für diejenigen die an long kovid
leiden oder diejenigen die es nicht
bekommen wollen denn viele können sich
ja auch gar nicht selbst so gut schützen
junge Leute beispielsweise mit einer
chronischen Erkrankung anorheumatischen
Erkrankung zum Beispiel einem
immundefizit wir wissen dass viele
Menschen auch jüngere Leute einen
immuntobelin g oder einen immung Berlin
also Mangel haben das wird zum Teil
substituiert aber wir haben einfach ein
höheres Risiko und die sind auch darauf
angewiesen dass wir sie schützen die
können sich selbst nicht komplett
schützen das ist alles Gegenstand dieser
Kampagne ich bin daher sehr dankbar dass
Frau Stokowski uns heute begleitet eine
Autorin deren Arbeit ich persönlich sehr
schätze diese Randbemerkung sei mir hier
gestattet und sie wird über ihre also
ihre Erfahrungen gleich berichten wir
haben die also Werke vorgestellt ich
will darauf hinweisen dass wir hier Kre
Gefäß von also Rafael Brinkert
unterstützt worden sind der uns also
hier geholfen hat wir haben lange
darüber nachgedacht wie wir diese
Kampagne machen können dass sie
kreativer ist als vielleicht das ein
oder andere was wir in diesem
Zusammenhängen in der Vergangenheit
gesehen haben und es geht hier einfach
darum keine Angst zu machen echt
Schicksale nichts ist gefehlt keine Fake
News die Leute ich erzählen ihre
Geschichten sie kommen freiwillig sie
kommen aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft
sie berichten wie es ihnen ergeht die
Kampagne wird aufgespielt im Fernsehen
in den also im Radio auf Plakatflächen
in den sozialen Netzwerken aber auch in
den Zeitungen wir wollen damit die
Impfquote erreichen insbesondere auch
bei den über 60-Jährigen dort fehlt nach
wie vor 70 Prozent die vierte Impfung
ich hatte eben schon ausgeführt dass das
Sterberisiko bei dieser Gruppe durch die
vierte Impfung um 90 Prozent gesenkt
werden kann im Vergleich Risiko wenn man
schon drei Impfungen hat das ist
zumindest die Lage einiger sehr
wichtiger Studien und wir wollen auch
all diejenigen erreichen die also
einfach bereit sind dann wieder die
Maske zu tragen lassen Sie mich
schließen mit einem ehrlichen Wort in
Richtung der Bundesländer
es ist jetzt wirklich an der Zeit die
Fallzahlen steigen die Zahl der
Todesfälle mit und an Corona steigt die
Intensivstationen
belegen sich zunehmend und sind in
einigen Bereichen bereits vor der
Überlastung wir haben darüber hinaus
keinen Grund anzunehmen dass die Welle
die wir jetzt vor uns haben dass sie
sich selbst
begrenzt das heißt es wird einfach immer
so weitergehen und die Frage ist
zumindest für die nächsten Wochen wird
es so weitergehen da wird es vielleicht
mal etwas langsamer steigen dann wieder
schneller steigen dann wieder etwas
langsamer steigen aber die Richtung in
die wir unterwegs sind ist keine gute
und wir wissen aus der Pandemie je
früher man die Bremse tritt
desto besser ist es weil wir müssen
lange auf der Bremse bleiben daher wäre
es sinnvoll mit geringen Einschränkungen
jetzt zu arbeiten als mit sehr
drastischen Einschränkungen später zu
reagieren das ist mein Appell wirklich
an die Länder dass die Länder überlegen
ob nicht jetzt schon darüber nachgedacht
werden sollte machen wir in den
Innenräumen die Masken die Masken zur
Pflicht weil es ist etwas was viele
Bürger mittlerweile auch wünschen ich
schließe mich der Präsidentin der
Bundesärztekammer Frau der der Marburger
bundesfrau Johanna an die gestern gesagt
hat wir müssen darüber nachdenken denn
mit dem Masken tragen in den Innenräumen
können wir die jetzige Welle gut
begrenzen die Länder müssen das
überlegen müssen schauen wie steht die
Pandemie muss also darüber nachgedacht
waren wann ist der optimale Zeitpunkt
aber wir sind eigentlich mit allen
Instrumenten optimal
Impfstoffe sind da wir haben eine gute
Kampagne die stellen wir heute vor wir
haben gute Daten keiner kann sagen wir
können jetzt nicht reagieren uns fehlen
die Daten das wäre abwegig einen Blick
auf den pandemeradar zeigt dass die
Daten da sind wir brauchen auf nichts zu
warten das abwassermonitoren zum
Beispiel an den sechs Plätzen wo es
jetzt machen zeigt ganz klar es geht
aufwärts mit den Fahrzeugen wir haben
die Medikamente da wir haben das
Infektionsschutzgesetz darüber ist das
Ganze den ganzen Sommer glaube es ist
darüber gearbeitet worden somit also
können wir das jetzt beherrschen wir
können das begrenzen und dann ist es
nicht so dass in diesem schwierigen
Herbst auch noch die coronakrise ein
großes Thema würde vielen Dank
Lauterbach ein technischer Hinweis von
mir bzw einen dringende Bitte an die
Fotografin Fotografen doch bitte
pfleglich mit unseren Mikrofonen
umzugehen das sind auch ihre
Mitgliedsbeiträge die womöglich für eine
Reparatur verwendet werden müssen
raschkuckowski bitteschön
ja hallo mein Name ist Margarete
stukowski ich bin hier heute das
abschreckungsbeispiel für longo wird
normalerweise bin ich Autorin bzw ich
war es vorher
meine Infektion war im Januar ich war
dreimal geimpft also ich war ziemlich
frisch geboostet und seitdem bin ich
krank
und seit ein paar Wochen bin ich so
halbwegs auf dem Weg der Besserung aber
es gibt immer noch sehr viele Tage an
denen ich einfach nur
im Bett liegen kann und das ist dann
auch nicht so entspannt wie das immer
klingt mit dem Bett liegen und so also
man liegt dann mit Symptomen im Bett
und
ja ich finde sehr gut und richtig dass
es diese
Aufklärungskampagne jetzt gibt
und gleichzeitig wurde ich gebeten aus
meiner Perspektive zu sprechen
und
als longbourit Betroffene und dann muss
ich sagen ich sehe das total viele Leute
auch eigentlich gut informierte Leute
überhaupt keine Ahnung von longkurved
haben also ich Fragen auf Leute bist du
eigentlich noch so müde
müde ist echt nicht mein Problem ich
schlafe oft 14 Stunden oder so
ich habe andere Symptome
oder Leute
setzen longkow wird quasi mit so einer
Art Burnout oder Depression oder so
gleich beides habe ich nicht
oder haben so Vorstellungen dass man so
ein verdienter Auszeit irgendwie hat
durch so einen Coach antragung
und das trifft halt alles nicht zu das
ist alles ziemlicher Quatsch und wenn es
jetzt nur eine Aufklärungskampagne wäre
dann würde ich natürlich
kritisch mich äußern weil
es dann so wäre dass es einfach nur
Individualisierung der
Verantwortlichkeiten wäre bzw eine
Fortsetzung dessen deswegen bin ich froh
dass es jetzt diese Diskussionen gibt
über
ob die meisten Pflicht dann Innenraum
wieder eingeführt wird und ich hoffe
dass das passiert wobei
Größe auch davon mir ich habe mich
draußen angesteckt
und also ich bin sehr sehr sicher in
welchem Moment das war und das war
draußen
von daher kann ich persönlich dazu raten
auch draußen niemals zu tragen wenn man
Leute trifft
und natürlich
hoffen Leute wie ich weiß nicht ob du
auf irgendwer noch über Luftfilter an
Schulen oder so diskutieren wird dieses
Jahr aber
das würde ich mir natürlich auch
wünschen und ähm das wäre natürlich die
Leute vor longkowitz
nicht nur waren sondern auch den helfen
die es jetzt schon haben und da gibt es
im Moment viel zu wenig Informationen zu
wenig Behandlungsmöglichkeiten und zu
viel Bürokratie
für mich ist heute der
264 zu Tag ab Symptom beginnen mein
akuter Verlauf war einigermaßen mild und
danach wurde ich dann halt nicht mehr
gesund ich habe dann long-coburg
bekommen in Form von täglichen krassen
Kopfschmerzen fatik Herzrasen Schwindel
kribbeln und verschiedenen Körperteilen
Konzentrationsstörung
Wortfindungsstörungen und diese ganzen
anderen als brainfourk bekannten
Phänomene und eine starke
belastungsintoleranz und das bedeutet
dass sämtliche Symptome sich bei
Belastung verschlimmern und Belastung
kann halt auch sowas sein wie man geht
zum Supermarkt man duscht man
telefoniert also es können sehr banale
Sachen sein und dieses verschlimmern
heißt
dass man dann mehrere Stunden oder
mehrere Tage ist einem sehr schlecht
geht als ich zum ersten Mal in solchen
Crash hatte dachte ich ich habe ein
Herzinfarkt also so Einschätzung wie
sich das anfühlt das ist nicht schön
ich habe dabei noch eigentlich
dreifaches Glück im Unglück weil ich
erstens einen Arzt habe der longo wird
ernst nimmt ich war auch schon bei
anderen Ärzten die das absolut nicht
ernst genommen haben
einer davon der sogar eine long-gruppe
Sprechstunde anbietet
es war grotesk aber egal jedenfalls habe
ich einen Arzt der sich darum kümmert
zweitens wenn mein Freund mich pflegt
und für mich einkaufen geht und kocht
und diese ganzen Sachen macht die ich
nicht mehr so gut machen kann
und drittens weil ich vorher ganz okay
verdient habe und deswegen jetzt noch
nicht arm bin durch die Krankheit ich
sage noch weil ich nicht weiß wann ich
gesund werde
und sich ja auch viertens weil ich nicht
so viele Deppen in meinem Umfeld habe
die generell Corona sind oder irgendwo
wird für
Beamten oder Künstler Hysterie halten
oder so
die Versorgungslage bei Logo wird es
weiterhin sehr schlecht ich habe jetzt
seit Anfang des Jahres die Krankheit und
mein erster Termin in der lonkovic
Sprechstunde in der Charité hier in
Berlin ist in der zweiten Novemberhälfte
und das war der frühestmögliche Termin
aktuell habe ich dann zusätzlich noch
das bürokratische Problem dass meine
Krankenkasse mich zwingen möchte einen
Reha zu beantragen das ist ein
Standardverfahren weil die Krankenkassen
nicht so lange Krankengeld bezahlen
wollen
allerdings gibt es keine Reha bei dem
was ich habe
im Gegenteil es gibt eine starke
Empfehlung der WHO keine Reha zu machen
wenn man PEM hat PM heißt post
exectional my less das heißt das ist
diese Verschlechterung der Symptome nach
Anstrengung oder Belastung
es ist ein zentraler Punkt von mecfs
aber eben auch von Form von loncobit
ich weiß nicht ob den Krankenkassen
diese Empfehlung nicht bekannt ist oder
ob sie sie bewusst ignorieren es geht
natürlich ums Geld in dem Fall
eine nicht geglückte Reha ist
gleichzeitig ein Rentenantrag und dann
zahlt halt die Rentenkasse und nicht die
Krankenkasse das ist der ganze
finanzielle Witz an der Sache aber es
gibt eben Leute mit lonkovit die in so
einen real reingehen ohne Rollstuhl und
im Rollstuhl wieder rauskommen
weil das
Belastung und so sollte man vermeiden
ich habe jetzt gerade schon im ecfs
gesagt dass es die schwerste Form von
weil die Forschung dazu und die
Aufklärung darüber über Jahrzehnte
vernachlässigt wurde gibt es jetzt auch
so wenig Hilfe bei lungenkowith und ich
habe bisher über 1000 Euro ausgegeben
für Sachen wo ich rumprobiert habe ob
sie mir helfen also Medikamente
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel
Kompressionskleidung eine Apple watch
mit der man ein EKG machen kann
Botox gegen Kopfschmerzen
manche sagen haben geholfen manche nicht
aber es hat halt auch nicht jeder über
1000 Euro um ein bisschen rum zu
probieren
Leon Kobelt und mezfs sind beides keine
tödlichen Krankheiten man stirbt
eigentlich nicht daran aber fürs weiß
man jetzt schon dass es da eine ziemlich
hohe Suizidrate gibt
und das liegt nicht nur daran dass diese
Leute schwer krank sind sondern auch
daran dass sie zu wenig
gesellschaftliche Unterstützung bekommen
und dadurch jede Art von Hoffnung auf
Besserung verlieren und das hat auch
politische Gründe mangelnde Forschung
mangelnde Versorgung und Unterstützung
und diejenigen die man dann öffentlich
manchmal nur hört mit longkowith oder
mecfs es klingt dann immer so wie ja
warum sie kann jetzt hier sitzen sie
kann jetzt sich irgendwie unterhalten
oder mal ein Interview geben oder so ja
das heißt dass diese Leute entweder
wahrscheinlich gerade ein ausnimmt guten
Tag haben oder sich über ihre Kräfte
hinaus engagieren und danach bestraft
werden und wieder im Bett liegen müssen
mit Schmerzen und mit Schwindel
jetzt ist es so dass viele der
Geschichten die man im Moment in den
Medien berichten liest
über nonkovit Betroffene so gehen ja
einfach Marathonläufer und er war
leitende Angestellter und jetzt kommt er
kaum noch die Treppe hoch oder sie hat
dein Unternehmen und sie will unbedingt
wieder arbeiten sie haben vorhin auch
gesagt haben Leute promoviert die hatten
tolle Jobs und so
und es stimmt ja auch alles es stimmt
das ist gesunde aktive high performance
Menschen treffen kann
ich finde das ein bisschen gruselig weil
dabei halt immer wieder betont wird dass
die Leute unbedingt wieder gerne
arbeiten wollen und leisten wollen und
so so jetzt müsste man immer noch
beweisen dass es nicht um Faulheit geht
und es ist aber natürlich so dass auch
arme vorher schon Kranke faule und
unsportliche Leute longo wird bekommen
und darunter genauso leiden vielleicht
sogar noch mehr wenn sie arm sind und
sich diese ganzen Experimente nicht
leisten können
und
vielleicht auch Leute die nicht das
Glück haben sozial gut abgesichert zu
haben die haben keinen haben der sie
pflegt
und vielleicht auch nicht so guten
Hausarzt haben also was ich mir wünsche
wäre weiterhin Aufklärung
ausgewogene Berichterstattung und
wesentlich mehr Forschung zu lanco wird
und mecfs mehr Kostenübernahme durch die
Krankenkassen mehr Fortbildung für
Ärztinnen und Ärzte
weil wenn das nicht passiert dann hängt
es wie bisher von Privilegien Geld und
Glück ab ob man diese Krankheit schafft
zu besiegen und das wäre bitte danke
schön
Dankeschön bis hierher dann sind wir bei
Fragen und starten mit dem ZDF Frau
Spiekermann wenn sie sich auch kurz
vorstellen
sie haben ja im Prinzip alles richtig
gemacht also sie sagen die mehrfach
geimpft gewesen und dementsprechend auch
wir können Sie ganz schlecht verstehen
ich sagte Entschuldigung weil es ein
bisschen weit weg ist sie sagen ja dass
sie mehrfach geimpft sind also auch wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe
wie erklären sie sich dass sie trotzdem
so derartig erkrankt sind und
gleichzeitig werden sie auch für
Impfungen haben sie dadurch auch im
Zweifel dass das möglicherweise nicht so
geschützt hat wie sie sich das erhofft
haben weil sie ja trotz Impfung schwer
erkrankt
wie erkläre ich mir das keine Ahnung
kann ich mir nicht erklären also es ist
so
ich kenne auch Leute die nicht geimpft
waren und longkowelt haben von daher
also keine Ahnung wie das bei mir
gelaufen wäre wenn ich nicht geimpft
gewesen wäre natürlich hätte ich gehofft
dass die Impfungen mich auch voll und
kobit schützt und es scheint ja rein
statistisch bei vielen Leuten so zu sein
ich war vorher einigermaßen gesund also
das weswegen ich in Meinung war spielt
keine Rolle sowas wie
Schilddrüsentabletten das nehmen viele
Frauen in meinem Alter
und hatte keine relevanten
Vorerkrankungen
von daher
weiß ich nicht
warum ich
so erkrankt bin und
klar hätte ich mir gewünscht dass die
Impfungen mich davor schützt aber ich
würde trotzdem allen Leuten raten sich
impfen zu lassen weil ich weiß nicht wie
es mir ergangen wäre wenn ich nicht
kämpft gewesen wäre
ja vielen Dank dass ein sehr wichtige
Frage von dem was die Studien bisher
zeigen geht man davon aus dass für
diejenigen die geimpft sind das
longkowitrisiko sich um die Hälfte
verringert das heißt es bleibt ein
Risiko übrig aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit
lonkovic zu bekommen wenn man sich trotz
Impfung infiziert hat ist deutlich
reduziert den Faktor kann man nicht
genau sagen beste Studienlage also
zusammenfassend ist ungefähr Faktor 0,5
das ist schon mal sehr bedeutsam es
kommt allerdings dazu und das natürlich
mit der Impfung auch das Risiko dass ich
mich überhaupt infiziere singt somit
muss ich das ja auch beachten und das
ist gerade bei den neuen Impfstoffen
wahrscheinlich beachtlich da fehlen uns
noch die entsprechenden Daten aus der
Fläche aber da ist ja ein ba5
angepasster Impfstoff ist den wir jetzt
in unserer Kampagne auch also
mit
empfehlen und die ba5 Variante derzeit
die dominierende Variante ist gehen wir
davon aus dass die Impfstoffe jetzt
wieder besser vor Ansteckung schützen
als es der Fall gewesen ist als wir die
alten Impfstoffe verimpfen mussten um
neue Varianten zu bekämpfen wir haben
jetzt die neuen Impfstoffe die genau
diese neuen Varianten also abdecken und
damit rechnet man mit einer besseren
Schutzwirkung vor Ansteckung aus dem
Laborexperimenten gehen wir auch davon
aus dass das so kommt weil die also
schon der Schutz vor Infektion
korreliert in den lab Studien auch in
den Tierstudien aber auch in den
menschenverlaufs Studien bei den
Vorhaben bei den vorherigen Impfstoffen
mit dem Twitter der neutralisierenden
Antikörper und der Täter der
neutralisierenden Antikörper ist jetzt
auf ba5 bezogen die Variante die wir
derzeit haben sehr viel höher mit dem
neuen Impfstoffen somit gehen wir davon
aus dass Risiko sich zu infizieren sinkt
wenn man geimpft ist und wenn man sich
dann trotzdem infiziert dann sinkt
wiederum das risikolonkurve zu bekommen
aber man muss darauf hinweisen daher
stimme nicht zu das ist nicht also das
kann absolute Sicherheit wir werden
daher in dieser Kampagne ich schütze
mich nicht nur für die Impfung sondern
wir werben auch davor wir werden auch
dafür dass man sich mit der Maske
schützt der massenschutz ist sehr sehr
wichtig am besten ist maskenschutz und
Impfung
ja also eben auch zu Impfkampagne die
heißt ja ich schütze mich früher war es
ja eher das Argument der Solidarität was
hat
sich dafür in der Tat also ist es so
dass zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt die
Bereitschaft sich selbst
impfen zu lassen um Dritte zu schützen
nicht mehr so ausgeprägt ist wie das am
Anfang der Pandemie war weil jeder quasi
jetzt denkt na ja der dritte der den ich
jetzt schützen soll der kann sich selbst
schützen indem er sich impfen lässt es
sind ja nur wenige oder Schutz durch die
Impfung dann also nicht wirklich
durchdringend ist weil zum Beispiel die
Schutzwirkung wegen Vorerkrankungen
nicht reich wir haben da Gruppen wo wir
also sehr häufig impfen müssen um die
Impfwirkung zu erreichen Krebspatienten
immunsuppinierte also Patienten nur zum
Teil fünf oder sechs Mal geimpft werden
muss um neutralisierende also
antikörperkonzentrationen im hohen
dreistelligen Bereich wenigstens zu
erreichen somit also ist der Schwerpunkt
also auf ich schütze mich weil wir
realistischerweise davon ausgehen dass
etwas also wichtigste Motiv ist wir
haben aber auch Leute die dann einfach
sagen also ich schütze mich in einer
lustigen Art und Weise dass man sieht
das ist auch ein Appell an andere macht
ihr doch das gleiche somit ist das nicht
nur auf die personenbezogen sondern man
spricht auch damit andere an denen es so
geht und wir versuchen wirklich lustige
Motive zu kombinieren mit also Motiven
die dann wiederum nicht so lustig sind
jeden Tag ein neues Motiv jeden Tag
spricht ein Mensch über sein Schicksal
oder seine Motive und dass du mir dann
rapida Wechsel 84 Menschen sprechen weil
jeder spricht für eine Million Bürger
also für die 84 Millionen Bürger spricht
je ein Mensch und der Mensch der sagt
dann eben also wie es ihm gegangen ist
wenn ich jetzt selbst einen schlauen
Spruch oder so versuchen sollte auf die
Schnelle zu entwickeln dann würde ich
zum Beispiel Richtung gehen und dass ich
mich Schütze damit ich weiter Studien in
der Nacht lesen kann und nicht zum
Gegenstand von Studien werde oder so
etwas also so sagen also sagen wir
manche Leute quasi aus ihrem Leben
heraus sie sehen da die Motive dass also
wieso wieso sie das machen das klingt
erstmal so lustig aber ist wenn man
darüber nachdenkt dann wiederum gar
nicht mehr so lustig denn wenn man also
zum Beispiel entwickelt dann so ist es
in mit dem nächtlichen Lesen von
komplizierten Studien zumindest für eine
Zeit lang vorbei dann machen wir weiter
bei dem Kollegen neben Frau
auf ZDF Herr Lauterbach eine Frage zu
den Impfstoffen br5 haben sie gesagt ist
die Variante die gerade vorherrscht dann
gibt es ja die Variante bq11 wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe wenn du unter
Linie von ba5 mit 5 Mutationen also fünf
Aminosäuren austauschen an einem
spike-protein bedeutet das dass der
Impfstoff dann im November Dezember wenn
bq11 vorherrschend werden sollte nicht
mehr ganz so gut schützt vor Infektionen
und vielleicht auch vor schweren Verlauf
rechnen sie dann also auch mit einem
Anstieg der
Infektionszahlen ja vielen Dank das
wissen wir zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht
was wir wissen ist das Beko 1.1 in den
Vereinigten Staaten derzeit also stark
zunimmt da erreichen mich auch Daten von
Wissenschaftlern mit denen ich also eng
zusammengearbeitet habe auch in der
Vergangenheit und ich glaube dass da
noch mehr zu sehen ist als das was in
der offiziellen Statistik bisher
ausgewiesen ist
das muss man also ganz genau im Auge
behalten ich bin da auch im Austausch
mit
dem Berater von Joe Biden im Weißen Haus
der ein Kollege von mir aus der Zeit in
Bonn noch ist und wir sehen Beko 1.1
nimmt stark zu hat also eine viel
stärkere also
immuniversion und gehört zu dieser
Gruppe von also Varianten die man
Pentagon also Varianten irgendwo also
bestimmte also
Punktmutationen sind die an den
Impfungen gut vorbeikommen darüber jetzt
zu spekulieren wie gut an dem Stoffe
noch sind wissen wir nicht das wird
jetzt keinen Sinn machen klar ist jetzt
ist erst einmal die ba5 Variante die
dominierende Variante und das ist auch
ganz klar dass sag mal wenn man sich das
also wenn man sich die Zusammensetzung
der Mutationen anschaut ist der
Impfschutz den wir erwarten können mit
der jetzigen ba5 adaptierten
impfstoffvariante und auch der ba1
adaptierten bivalenten Variante besser
als das was wir mit dem ancestralen
Impfstoff hätten erwarten können somit
schneller Antwort wir wissen es nicht
genau schnelle Antwort ist das muss man
sehr genau im Auge behalten schnelle
Antwort ist in Amerika deutliche Zunahme
mehr als in der offiziellen Statistik
und also ich glaube dass wir mit den
Impfstoffen die wir jetzt bekommen da
einen guten Schutz hinbekommen genaues
Ausmaß ist nicht klar
Zusatz gerne noch das bedeutet wir
müssen ein bisschen auf die Zeit achten
aber gerne das bedeutet es gibt ja diese
Studie von den Helmholtz Leuten die
sagen die dritte Variante ist könnte
eine neue Variante kommen die wieder zu
Fall Anstiegen führt das könnte schon
durchaus drin sein das könnte sein ja
dann bitte
ganz kurz weil sie die Statistiken
angesprochen haben glauben Sie dass Sie
die dass die
Infektionszahlen in Deutschland derzeit
zuverlässig sind wenn man bedenkt dass
viele Fälle nicht mehr gemeldet werden
und die eigentliche Frage man hat ja
letzte Woche Fall meinen Anstieg im
Süden festgestellt manchmal behaupten es
gab einen Zusammenhang mit dem
Oktoberfest sehen sie da eine Verbindung
hätte man das vielleicht im Nachhinein
so nicht veranstalten soll
ja ich glaube dass die Zahlen die wir
haben zuverlässig sind aber nicht
vollständig weil wir natürlich eine
untererfassung haben bei denjenigen die
nur den antigentest machen und nicht den
pcr-bestätigungstest machen daher
rechnen wir mit einer Dunkelziffer dass
die Gesamtzahl drei bis viermal so hoch
ist wie das was wir jetzt auswerten und
das bedeutet dass wir derzeit
möglicherweise nicht also 100.000 neue
Fälle haben sondern wenn man alle Fälle
zählen würde bis zu 400.000 Fällen das
könnte durchaus sein es kann auch sein
dass es 300.000 Fälle sind aber wir
haben eine erhebliche Dunkelziffer und
trotzdem ist der pandemierer da sehr
wichtig weil wir sehen wir erfassen ganz
gut bei den über 60-Jährigen bei den
über 60-Jährigen also ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
Bestätigungstest durch den PCR gemacht
wird sehr hoch weil die meisten über
60-Jährigen wenn sie sich infizieren auf
Symptome entwickeln das führt zum
Arztbesuch das führt typischerweise auch
dazu dass dann der PCR gemacht wird
daher haben wir in der Altersgruppe die
wir besonders erreichen müssen haben wir
gute Daten zum und wir haben auf jeden
Fall viel bessere Daten als wie hatten
allen Datenpunkte extrem wichtig ist wie
viele belegbare Betten haben wir
eigentlich noch auf den
Intensivstationen da denkt der Leier
immer das ist nicht so also wild wenn da
die Leute kommen mit kovid also dann ist
das dann ist das nicht so gefährlich und
so das war vollkommen falsch wenn ein
Patient auf die Intensivstation kommt
nach einer Operation dann liegt er da
typischerweise einen Tag zu Überwachung
oder zwei Tage und geht dann auf die
Normalstation wenn ich aber einen Kurve
Patienten auf der hilft das Sohn habe
dann liegt er oft viel länger und somit
laufen die Intensivstationen sehr
schnell voll wenn wir jetzt mal diese
schweren Fälle haben jetzt kann man
sagen die Fälle sind ja nicht mehr so
schwer wir haben nicht mehr so viel
Ecken das hat zwei Gründe zum einen da
vielen älteren Leuten wird jetzt ECMO
gar nicht mehr gestartet weil wir hatten
bei egmo in Deutschland eine
Sterblichkeit von 70 Prozent und bei den
älteren die wir mit Ecken versorgt haben
weil die Sterblichkeit noch sehr viel
höher somit ich werde oft also von Laien
angesprochen das gar nicht so wild sein
wir haben doch viel weniger eckenofälle
naja weil die ecofälle sich auch nicht
als so wirkungsvoll erwiesen haben bei
den sehr Arten Fällen die werden heute
nur noch beatmet aber ich wollte
jemanden für kurvit beatmen muss ob da
jetzt älter ist oder jünger was auch
immer dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass er stirbt 50 Prozent
ist das jetzt viel besser als früher als
wir Omegon noch nicht hatten nein damals
sind uns auch 50 Prozent gestorben somit
können wir überhaupt nicht von alle
harmlosen Situation ausgehen es ist
leider so diejenigen die schwer
erkranken Stichwort weiße Lunge stehe
ich Wort also und es gibt auch einfach
dass ich einmal gesagt haben bevor ich
das vergesse haben wenig Zeit aber es
muss einmal gesagt werden es wird immer
gesagt die die Statistik überschätzt
also die corona-toten war viele auch mit
kovic sterben die werden sonst nicht
gestorben das ist in der Regel auch
schon falsch denn wenn ich mit also
Corona sterbe kann es trotzdem so sein
dass ich ohne die corona-infektion nicht
gestorben wäre das ging viele nicht
auseinander die denken dann mit Corona
gestorben bedeutet der wäre sowieso
gestorben das ist aber falsch so denkt
der Laie sondern mit Corona gestorben
bedeutet dass es durchaus sein kann dass
er ohne die corona-infektion die
zusätzlich gekommen ist nicht gestorben
und der Leier immer wieder werde ich
angesprochen der ist doch mit Corona
gestorben dann im Hinterkopf ist dann
der wäre sonst nicht gestorben einfach
falsch und wir unterschätzen auch die
Todesfälle weil wir wissen dass nach der
corona-infektion für einen ganzes Jahr
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dann zu sterben
an einer herzkaiser-erkrankung Stichwort
Herzinfarkt und dergleichen Schlaganfall
deutlich erhöht ist die diese Leute
kommen aber alle nicht in die Statistik
derjenige der jetzt Corona gehabt hat
und sechs Monate später an einem
Herzinfarkt wird der kommt nie in die
corona-statistik die müssen aber
eigentlich auch gezählt werden weil der
Mensch wäre ohne die Infektion nicht
gestorben daher muss das einmal gesagt
werden diese Verharmlosung ist nicht
angemessen
der Zusammenhang mit dem Oktoberfest bei
noch gefragt
das natürlich ist das Oktoberfest so wie
es gemacht wurde eine schlechte Idee
gewesen
Absagen hätte man es schlecht können
weil dafür fehlte die rechtliche
Grundlage da darauf wird ja immer also
hingewiesen aber hätte man es besser
durchführen können oder sollen dass die
Antwort natürlich ja man hätte zum
Beispiel warnen müssen wer soll kommen
wer soll nicht kommen Menschen mit
Vorerkrankungen Menschen mit und so
weiter und so fort dann wäre das aller
Mindeste gewesen dass man jedem der dort
hinkommt einen Selbsttest angeboten
hätte den dann noch bei Eintritt
auswerte machen können und eine Stufe
besser wäre gewesen dass man den
Selbsttest oder den Test nach was
vorgegeben hätte da wird immer gesagt
das wäre mit den
investitionsschutzgesetz nicht machbar
gewesen und das ist natürlich falsch
weil ich kann natürlich im Rahmen des
Hausrechtes jederzeit
Farben machen für den Besuch meiner
Veranstaltung oder auch für den Besuch
einer also eines Lokals also sie vor
Welt die könnten wenn sie das wollten
hier ebenfalls im Rahmen ihres
hausrichtes also Vorgaben machen somit
ich finde wie es gemacht wurde war es
halt nicht gut
es muss jetzt nach vorne geblickt werden
es hilft nicht da also nachzutreten und
ich finde das daher sagen wir München
aber auch Bayern unter besonderer
Verpflichtung ist sich jetzt zu
überlegen was macht man mit der
maskenpflicht in den Innenräumen wenn
man es wirklich so laufen lassen denn
das geht ja zum Lasten der Pflegekräfte
so lassen es ärztlichen Personals das
geht zu lassen der Leute die dann in
sich infizieren oder infiziert werden
und krank werden blancovice man muss
jetzt darüber nachdenken wann ist der
richtige Zeitpunkt dass man die
Verantwortung zeigt dass
Infektionsschutzgesetz gibt das ja her
wir haben noch 20 Minuten und ich habe
noch sieben Wortmeldungen auf dem Zettel
wir machen weiter mit Herrn Rinke bitte
ja danke Herr Lauterbach Sie sich kurz
vorstellen ja Andreas Rinke von Reuters
Lauterbach ich hätte ganz gerne zur
Praxis louvit gefragt sie haben uns
darauf hingewiesen effektives Medikament
aber es gab immer wieder Klagen auch von
ihnen dass es zu wenig eingesetzt wird
dass Medikamente möglicherweise
verfallen was genau tun sie oder wollen
Sie tun damit paxlovit besser zum
Einsatz kommt und ich hatte mir
eigentlich auch von Ihnen eine Antwort
erhofft auf das was Frau Stokowski
gesagt hat weil sie als
Gesundheitsminister natürlich für einige
dieser Punkte mitverantwortlich sind
oder auf jeden Fall mit steuern können
also von einem kovic Sprechstunden bis
zu den Regelungen die Frau stockkowski
bei den Krankenkassen erwähnt hat also
vielleicht können Sie dazu auch noch was
sagen danke
ja vielen Dank zunächst also zum
paxlovit die also Nutzung von paxlowe
steigt und das haben wir erreicht durch
eine sehr gute Zusammenarbeit mit den
Hausärzten hier danke ich insbesondere
dem neuen Präsident des
haushaltsverbands haben dr Markus Beyer
mit dem wir sehr eng zusammenarbeiten
die Hausärzte haben an Empfehlungen
mitgearbeitet zusammen auch mit dem
Expertenrat der Bundesregierung
corona-experten hatte Bundesregierung
dass die Abgabe von paxovid einfach
vereinfacht wird indem es eine Leitlinie
gibt wo also sehr simpel beschrieben
wird wer kommt in Frage viele der
ursprünglichen
Kontraindikationen haben sich nicht
bestätigt so dass der Kreis derer wo das
Medikament genutzt werden kann viel
größer geworden ist
zum zweiten wird das Medikament auch von
den Hausärzten dispensiert sie tragen es
mit und sie arbeiten auch mit den Heimen
zusammen so dass wir dort die Versorgung
beschleunigt haben da wird das
Medikament zum Teil in den Haaren sogar
gelagert wir wollen daher die Erfolge
die mit dem Medikamente erreicht werden
konnten in den Vereinigten Staaten
wollen wir reproduzieren und wir sind
auf dem richtigen Weg es wird sehr viel
mehr eingesetzt als vorher wir werden
aber noch weitergehen und also sind dann
ständigen Austausch mit dem Hausarzt zu
verbannt
die der Verfall des Medikamentes ist
nicht zu erwarten wir haben auf
betreiben und auch mit Hilfe des
Paul-Ehrlich-Instituts erreicht dass die
Haltbarkeit verlängert werden konnte bis
in den Oktober des nächsten Jahres daher
rechne ich damit dass wir überhaupt
keinen also Verfall dort haben werden
und kann Verwurf wir werden also das
Medikament über die gesamte Strecke der
nächsten Monate einsetzen können und
zu
dem Punkt noch eine Ergänzung wir haben
auch Erfolge jetzt bei der Impfkampagne
mit den Hausärzten zusammen die
Hausärzte also beten jetzt sehr offensiv
und
evidenzbasiert die neuen Impfstoffe an
daher hatten wir gestern zum ersten mal
wieder seit langer Zeit an
sechsstelligen im Verfolg über 100.000
Impfungen an einem Tag es geht aufwärts
und die Kampagne fängt ja jetzt erst an
wir haben entschieden die Kampagne die
wir heute vorstellen jetzt zu beginnen
weil jetzt die das Bewusstsein für die
Welle da ist hätten wir die Kampagne
früher gemacht wer die Kampagne quasi
also hätte dann hätten wir das Pulver
verschossen bevor die Schlacht begonnen
hat das wollen wir aber nicht jetzt ist
das Bewusstsein da jetzt war es jeder es
geht los jetzt ist der Startschuss
Corona ist zurück
Pandemie kommt zurück die herbst- und
winterwelle beginnt jetzt kommt die
Kampagne die 84 Menschen die sich
erklären und wir haben gestern 100.000
Impfungen gehabt wir gehen davon bei
stockowski hatte ich also wir hatten
auch Vorgespräche ich finde es sehr
richtig und wichtig dass Frau stuckowski
auf diese Punkte hingewiesen hat die
Krankenkassen wollen zum Teil diese
jungen Leute ich sag mal aus steuern wir
gehen dann quasi aus dem Rechtskreis des
Beschäftigten der
Krankenkassenleistungen bekommt in die
Rentenversicherung über und das ist
natürlich nicht richtig darüber wir
müssen darüber reden natürlich muss eine
Erwerbsminderungsrente für diejenigen wo
es nicht anders geht möglich sein das
ist klar aber an dem Punkt sind ja viele
Gott sei Dank nicht und definitiv auch
nicht vor Stokowski wenn ich so frei
sprechen darf daher reden wir darüber
wie wir dort zu Regelungen kommen dass
da der Automatismus über die Reha in die
Erwerbsminderungsrente wieder gebrochen
werden kann war das ist ja ein
Automatismus der typischerweise zum
Tragen kommt bei älteren Menschen die
also dann tatsächlich im
erwerbsminderungsalter sind wo das dann
üblicher oder häufiger weg also wo das
auch richtig ist aber bei so jungen
Leuten wo wir ja durch bessere
Medikamente und Versorgung die Sache
noch in den Griff bekommen werden die
Wissenschaft kämpft ja dafür ist das
nicht der richtige Weg daher sind wir da
also an Regelungen ich bitte um
Verständnis dass ich das vortragen
möchte wenn wir so weit sind aber mein
Haus ist also mit Fällen wie den Fällen
von Stokowski vertraut und wir arbeiten
auch daran etwas hinzubekommen wir
werden auch in Kürze ihnen etwas
vortragen wo es darum geht wie kann man
eigentlich die Versorgungsforschung bei
lonkovit verbessern wir haben da viel zu
wenig Versorgungsforschung da werde ich
einen also Vorschlag machen Deutschland
hat dazu wenig gemacht also eine sehr
offensive und große Initiative hoffe ich
Ihnen in kurzer vorstellen zu können wo
es darum geht wie kann Deutschland bei
der Versorgung der lonkovic-patienten
also wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse
generieren aber gleichzeitig auch
herausfinden was ist die beste
Versorgung und wie vergrößern den Anteil
der institutssambulanzen und der
Spezialambulanzen
dann die nächste Frage bitte ganz hinten
geht genau ich kann nicht richtig sehen
welches Mikrofon sie brauchen so jetzt
haben wir es ja Charlotte kurz zum
Deutschen Ärzteblatt ich wollte auch
noch mal zur Nutzung von paxlovit Fragen
das hat es sich inzwischen erledigt Frau
Stokowski ich wollte sie noch fragen ob
sie Teil dieser 84 so eins dieser 84
Einzelschicksale jetzt sind oder wie sie
da in der Kampagne mitgearbeitet haben
nee ich bin da nicht mit dabei es ist
aber auch schwer mit mir gerade zwei
Termine innerhalb von kurzer Zeit zu
machen
also es war dann die Frage ob ich
entweder hier sprechen kann oder ein
Fototermin machen kann und
dann dachte ich spreche ich doch hier
ich kann also ich wenn man mit mir
gerade einen Termin macht dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch dass ich
wieder Absage von daher
ist es nicht so einfach
aber ich finde es gut und richtig dass
da auch longkow wird
mit bei ist
dann habe ich eine doppelte Wortmeldung
hier vorne
ja Patrick Holstein von der Apotheke
Herr Lauterbach sie hatten die
maskenpflicht jetzt mehrfach
angesprochen wie sieht's denn aus mit
der testpflicht würden sie sowas auch
befürworten oder sagen wir mal
Änderungen testregime und eine ganz
kurze Frage zum eRezept wenn ich fragen
darf sie hatten diese Woche im Bundestag
gesagt Sie wollen das neue organisieren
was haben sie damit gemeint und zwar
einerseits technisch und andererseits
Gesetzgeber euch danke schön
ja bei der testlich sind die Dinge ja
sehr klar und arrondiert wir haben im
Infektionsschutzgesetz eben
festgehalten dass die Länder die
maskenpflicht im Innenraum beschließen
können und wenn Sie diese beschließen
dann müssen sie auch als Alternative den
Test anbieten als eine Möglichkeit die
also die die Maske nicht zu tragen also
diese Kombination haben wir ja als muss
Regelung gemacht und als kernregelung
dass diejenigen die frisch geimpft sind
oder frisch genesen gemessen an an der
drei monatsgrenze dass diese ebenfalls
von der maskenpflicht dann befreit sind
das sind die Regeln die richtig sind ich
glaube wir haben ein sehr gutes
Infektionsschutzgesetz es ist immer
wieder beklagt worden dass wir ein
strengeres Infektionsschutzgesetz
hätten als sie europäischen
Nachbarländer das stimmt aber mit zwei
Einschränkungen ich glaube dass die
Nachbarländer auch noch nachlegen werden
einfach nicht also
bisher zumindest aus meiner Sicht
vollständig vorbereitet sind und zum
zweiten hier das Gesetz ist genauso gut
wie es angewendet wird und da werden wir
natürlich noch beobachten was die Länder
jetzt mit dem Gesetz machen wie gesagt
wir haben dort Möglichkeiten die große
die großartig sind die aber auch genutzt
werden müssen beim eRezept bitte ich um
Verständnis wir haben also hier
uns also mit
Sicherheitsproblemen Sicherheitslücken
zu beschäftigen das tun wir auch sehr
intensiv und sobald wir diese Lücken
gelöst haben auch in technischer
Hinsicht würden wir darüber informieren
aber ich habe einfach darauf hingewiesen
weil der Roll-out sich ja jetzt etwas
verzögert dass das zum Teil auch also
technische Probleme das sind technische
Probleme dass wir hier ausdrücklich
sagen also die entstanden sind in der
Konzeptionsphase an der ich ja noch
nicht beteiligt gewesen bin aber wie Sie
wissen beschäftige ich mache also im
Rahmen der also Arbeit der nächsten also
zwölf Monate beschäftige ich mich ja mit
drei Punkten ganz schwerpunktmäßig neben
der corona-bewältigung eben zum einen
große krankenhausreformen dann eben
alles was mit Digitalisierung zu tun hat
von der Opt-Out EPA e-rezept digitale
Zwillinge
Kooperationsabkommen mit anderen Ländern
also es wird viel kommen also großes
Thema sein weil ich das für ganz ganz
zentralhalte und da sind wir in der
Aufarbeitung dessen was bisher gemacht
worden sind wir ein paar Architektur
Probleme aufgefallen die versuche ich zu
lösen welche weiter bin erzähle ich
Ihnen das ganz gerne auch hier
öffentlich aber ich arbeite jetzt
erstmal diese Probleme ab ich begrüße es
dass in der letzten Legislaturperiode da
viel gemacht wurde aber es ist auch sehr
schnell gearbeitet worden und da ist der
ein oder andere Punkt da muss man noch
mal herangehen der betrifft auf die
Sicherheit des erezeptes unter also
dritte Punkt euch auf also wo ich halt
heran möchte ist wir brauchen wieder
mehr soziale Gerechtigkeit in der
Gesundheitspolitik und zwar im Sinne was
tun wir für diejenigen die schwächer
sind was tun wir für unsere Kinder was
tun wir für die Vorsorge Medizin was tun
wir beispielsweise bei der Werbung für
bestimmte Lebensmittel die total
ungesund sind und sich an Kinder wenden
und so weiter Gesundheits-
all diese Punkte Widerstände gibt da
wird argumentiert die Gesundheitskurs
gebrauchen wenn nicht und zwar aber
diese Widerstände sind da damit wir sie
überwinden und wir werden tatsächlich in
diesen drei Bereichen in allen drei
Bereichen sind erhebliche Widerstände zu
erwarten große karnevalsreform können
sich vorstellen große Widerstände
Digitalisierung gab es schon immer
Widerstände jetzt soll endlich was
passieren große Widerstände
Fokus auf ärmere da wird man sagen da
ist doch schon alles auch große
Widerstände aber wir müssen daran gehen
da wird viel passieren in den nächsten
zwölf Monaten ich habe noch vier
Wortmeldungen auf meinem meiner Liste
die nächste Frage bitte
ja danke schön Laschet freie Journalist
drei kurze Fragen
welche Dauer und welche Zielquote bei
den über 60-Jährigen haben sie im Blick
ja vielen Dank wir haben keine
offizielle Zielgruppe jetzt ist ja die
vierte Impfung bei den über 60-Jährigen
also nur mit 28 Prozent also gegeben und
das muss deutlich besser werden somit
ist das sicherlich ein großer
Schwerpunkt den wir haben was wir bei
der vierten Impfung bei den über
60-Jährigen viel erreichen aber wir
waren auch viele jüngere erreichen und
also man muss nur schauen welche also
Empfehlungen wir da noch bekommen
übrigens ich möchte ja ausdrücklich
erwähnen auch im Rahmen der jetzt also
sehr guten Zusammenarbeit mit der STIKO
wir haben ja da eine neue also seiner
Institution geschaffen die peiko
Pandemien Impfkommission mit ein paar
zusätzlichen Wissenschaftlern die dabei
sind ich wohne den also Sitzungen der
STIKO jetzt auch selbst bei und also ich
freue mich dass dich Deko insbesondere
möchte ich hier ausdrücklich erwähnen
sich darauf verständigt hat was bei
denjenigen die in Pflegeeinrichtungen
Leben und schon vier Impfungen haben wo
die vierte Impfung aber lange zurücklegt
sechs Monate oder eine Infektion länger
als sechs Monate zurückliegt dass dort
ausdrücklich auch die fünfte Impfung
empfohlen wird dass die gründlich fünfte
Impfung auch gegeben werden dann war das
ist eine große Gruppe schätzen schätzen
Sie das bitte nicht falsch ein wenn der
Impfschutz bei der führt nach der
vierten Impfung bei den Bewohnern von
Pflegeeinrichtungen lange zurückliegt
reichte Impfstoff nicht mehr aus um das
wirklich abzudecken vor schwere
Erkrankungen wenn es uns gelingen sollte
in den Pflegeeinrichtungen hier wirklich
offensiv die also die die Impflücken zu
schließen und bei den dann doch
erkrankten mit paxlovic schnell
nachzurücken dann können wir da sehr
stark die Sterblichkeit senken
ach so bitte Entschuldigung was ist
genau die Frage das Budget ach so was
die Kampagne kostet die Kampagne kostet
etwa 32 Millionen Euro und die also
kreative Entwicklung der Kampagne die
also jetzt von unserem Haus aber im
Wesentlichen auch von der Agentur
Brinkert Lück und von Herrn Brinkert
selbst entwickelt worden das hat noch
einmal 700.000 Euro gekostet somit sind
das wenn man das alles umlegt also
sozusagen die Kosten der Kampagne und
die Entwicklung der Kampagne etwa 40
Cent pro Bundesbürger
dann herrscht mit den Gabeln aus Sie
sich kurz vorstellen
Minister sie sind ja seit Beginn der
Pandemie zahlreichen Anfeindungen
ausgesetzt gewesen zuerst als
Gesundheitspolitiker dann als Minister
jetzt gab es ja auch wieder konkrete
Bedrohungen Bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt
was macht das mit ihnen wie sehr geht
ihnen das an die Nieren wenn sie von
solchen Plänen erfahren und ganz kurz
noch also die Länder angesprochen haben
doch achtsam zu sein mit den Maßnahmen
und rechtzeitig die richtigen Maßnahmen
einzuziehen wenn die Welle jetzt stärker
wird denkt man auch darüber nach
vielleicht wieder eine nationalen
Notlage zu erklären um dem Bund dann
auch mehr Durchgriffsrechte einzuräumen
wenn die Länder nicht das tun was sie
tun sollen danke schön
vielen Dank ja zunächst einmal ich würde
so zu den aktuellen Ermittlungen möchte
ich nicht sagen das werden Sie verstehen
ich glaube die Gelegenheit noch einmal
nutzen um darauf hinzuweisen also ich
genieße halt einen sehr also
umfänglichen Schutz durch das
Bundeskriminalamt und also hier war ja
also bei dem Vorgang der besprochen wird
von ihnen auch
vorgesehen wer das also so gelaufen wäre
dass auch die dass die Beamten selbst
gefährdet gewesen wer stark gefährdet
gewesen wären das haben sie ja
mitbekommen und daher möchte ich mich
bei den also beim Beamten des
Bundeskriminalamts auch mal hier
bedanken weil also ich weiß dass diese
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch ihre
Gesundheit
riskieren um mich zu schützen und das
machen sie ja nicht nur für mich sondern
auch für andere Bundespolitiker und
daher der Dank an dieser Stelle und also
was macht das mit mir ich mache einfach
meine Arbeit weiter also das ist nach
meiner Arbeit weiter und so also es gibt
viele Dinge die mich also erreichen die
mich bestürzen oder bedrücken aber das
hier ist einfach Teil meiner Arbeit und
das wird nicht dazu führen dass ich die
Arbeit anders mache als ich sie sonst
gemacht hätte also wir haben noch nie in
der also in den letzten Monaten überlegt
und dass ich etwas nicht sage was ich
eigentlich richtig fände weil das
möglicherweise einen
michgefährdenden Querdenker also
motiviert mobiler zu werden oder was
auch immer ich mache meine Arbeit und
werde da auch keiner ich erwähne keine
Veränderungen diesbezüglich
schließlich also nationaler Notfall
das wird nicht stattfinden wer war der
also bei dem Schutz den wir derzeit
jedem einzelnen anbieten können
Impfungen Masken und und Medikamente
Überblick über die Pandemie kann sich ja
jeder seine Panamera da ist ja nicht nur
für Politiker sondern auch für Bürger
wenn ich diese vier Maßnahmen diese vier
Ebenen zusammenziehe dann können die
allermeisten sich so gut schützen dass
also eine solche
notfalllage zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
überhaupt nicht also begründbar wäre
die vorletzte Frage bitteschön auf
unserer Seite dann ich kann es nicht
sehen ja doch hallo Medien die erste
Frage auf die Kampagne bezogen oder was
sie sind ja der Minister der behauptet
immer nachts Studium zu lesen sie zu
verstehen dann die Daten vorzutragen und
so weiter warum werden sie dann jetzt
nicht mehr mit Daten sondern mit 84
Anekdoten hat das was damit zu tun als
in Fakten Booster Fehler abgedruckt
wurden und die zweite Frage alle
Experten alle corona-zeiten ein bisschen
zu Christian Drosten sind sich einig
Infektionen sind kaum oder gar nicht zu
verhindern alle Menschen werden sich
früher oder später mehrfach infizieren
wir haben jetzt 186 Millionen Impfungen
34 Millionen festgestellte Infektionen
Dunkelziffer riesig was ist das Ziel
wann ist sozusagen die Grenze erreicht
wann sind es vier fünf sechs Impfungen 3
Infektionen eine Mischung aus sieben
also was ist das Ziel dieser dieser
ganzen Maßnahmen der Pandemie Schluss
die also
Motivation von Menschen sich also impfen
zu lassen oder sich zu schützen Maske zu
tragen gefährliche Veranstaltungen zum
alten Großveranstaltungen zu verwenden
das erreiche ich nicht indem ich eine
komplizierte Studie mit einer noch
komplizierteren Statistik in englischer
Sprache hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz vorstelle oder ins
Netz stelle also wir arbeiten schon mit
den ganz klassischen Methoden
der also Kommunikationspsychologie und
da gibt es ein Spektrum das ist klar
aber wir haben uns hier eben entschieden
mit echtmenschen zu arbeiten nicht mit
Schauspielern nicht mit fiktiven fällen
sondern hier treten 84 Bürger nach vorne
die also ihr Schicksal oder ihre
Überzeugung vortragen und also für die
große
Gruppe in der Gesellschaft sprechen für
die Mehrheit das sind die Menschen die
für die breite Mehrheit sprechen und wir
wollen einfach dass wir noch mal
zusammenkommen somit ist diese Kampagne
aus meiner Sicht auch etwas ich schütze
mich das ist auch etwas wie ein
Lagerfeuer und noch einmal die
zusammenkommen die die Pandemie weiter
ernst nehmen und versuchen durch diesen
schweren Herbst oder Winter
durchzukommen das ist ein Lagerfeuer der
vernünftigen diese Kampagne ich schütze
mich ist ein Lagerfeuer der vernünftigen
wo wir bei schlechterem Wetter und Kälte
zusammenkommen uns nochmal zusammen
nehmen und sagen ich schütze mich weil
ich vernünftig bin und das sind das sind
Menschen die das tausendmal besser
motivieren und vortragen können als ich
es mit meinen nächtlich evaluierten
Studien je könnte der zweite Punkt ist
also wo läuft das Ganze hinaus also es
ist übrigens nicht so dass also
erdrossen jemals sagen würde zumindest
im expertenrather das nicht gesagt und
auch in den vielen Gesprächen die ich
mit ihm für bin sicher dass ich mit
Herrn Drosten mehr Gespräche führe als
sie das tun aber er hat mir gegenüber
noch nicht erwähnt dass er davon ausgeht
dass ich jeder infiziert das hat auch
also sonst kein Mitglied aus dem
Expertenrat zumindest in Expertenrat
bisher vorgetragen das ist einfach nicht
zu erwarten dass ich jeder infiziert
Strecke nach vorne geblickt ist ich
persönlich und da bin ich Optimist
glaube dass wir Impfstoffe bekommen
werden auch wenn das bisher noch nicht
da ist aber wir werden Impfstoffe
bekommen die vor der Infektion gut
schützen
wahrscheinlich nasale Impfstoffe oder
inhalative Impfstoffe die eine
Schleimhaut Immunität darstellen so dass
der Schutz vor der Infektion noch besser
ist als er jetzt ist aber jetzt sagen
wir ruhig mal es wäre ihre
pessimistische Annahme wäre also richtig
und also es könnte gar nicht vermieden
werden dass ich sag mal in fünf oder
sechs Jahren sich jeder infiziert hätte
sagen wir es wäre wirklich richtig was
ich falsch finde aber sagen wir
unterhalten den Gedanken für eine
Sekunde dann macht es für mich einen
Unterschied ob Leute in sechs Jahren
möglicher schwer möglicherweise schwer
erkranken und wenn sie älter sind dann
möglicherweise auch versterben oder ob
sie es jetzt tun also wenn der jetzt
80-jähr sich in sechs Jahren infiziert
und dann möglicherweise an einem
schweren Verlauf verstirbt dann hat er
bis dahin noch sechs Jahre gelebt und
daher ist diese defätistische Haltung
wir machen nichts mehr weil es erwischt
zum Schluss je das ist zum einen
wissenschaftlich nicht korrekt und zum
zweitens ist eine zynische Haltung denn
in einer solchen Haltung könnte ich auch
die Krebsbehandlung einstellen mit der
gleichen also hart und kann ich hingehen
und sagen bei jemandem der jetzt an
Krebs erkrankt ist wo ich die fünf
Jahres Überlebensquote verbessere wir
sagen Moment in fünf Jahren ist er doch
sowieso tot dann könnte ich dann auch
aufhören somit das ist einfach kein
diese dieser Defätismus ist mir und auch
der Bundesregierung nicht zu eigen
und zum Schluss ganz schnell noch was
Spiekermann
sie haben gerade gesagt dass sie den
stikositzungen dass sie an diesen Teilen
nehmen passt das damit zusammen dass das
ein unabhängiges Gremium ist und wenn
sie sagen die Kliniken sind überlastet
hat das ja hauptsächlich damit zu tun
dass es an Pflegepersonal sammelt und
auch Betten gesperrt werden mussten wie
kann man denn diesen Teufelskreis also
dass man das Klinik immer diese gleichen
Grenzen kommen könnte man das durch zum
Beispiel durch eine Reform verändern
ja zunächst die sticko ist natürlich
vollkommen unabhängig und das beiwohnen
bedeutet nicht dass ich mitentscheide
kann damit diskutieren Fragen stellen
und dergleichen aber ich habe keinen
Einfluss auf die Beschlüsse und habe
auch keinerlei Stimmrecht aber es ist
natürlich wichtig dass der Minister sich
ein Bild auch verschafft über den
Verlauf der Diskussion um alle Argumente
rezipieren zu können und das mache ich
auch bei anderen Experten Gremien ich
also wohne auch beide in Sitzungen so
meine Service erlaubt das expertenrates
der Regierungskommission Krankenhaus
auch und auch im Expertenrat
pandemiebewältigung dann das ist einfach
tausendmal besser dass ich dazu höre und
Fragen stellen kann und den Verlauf
genau beachte als dass ich einen Bericht
bekomme den ich dann möglicherweise wenn
wir die Vorbildung fehlen würde was im
Moment Gott sei Dank nicht der Fall ist
aber wenn es mir fehlen würde nicht
richtig verstehen kann somit das ist
eine Verbesserung ist einfach für mich
besser aber ich beeinflusste natürlich
die Entscheid nicht und habe auch
keinerlei Stimmrecht die Unabhängigkeit
der STIKO ist nicht gefährdet zum
zweiten beim Pflegepersonal naja also
wir arbeiten am Pflegepersonal sie
wissen dass Krankenpfleger
entlastungsgesetz ist bereits durch das
Kabinett und seht vor das also eine
Entlastung auf den Stationen folgen wird
wir arbeiten also an vielen Ecken und
Enden an der Verbesserung der
Ausstattung mit Pflegepersonal und da
ist der Königsweg oder ein Königsweg den
wir jetzt in den nächsten Monaten machen
werden wir haben ja in Deutschland nicht
zu wenig Pflegepersonal sondern wir
haben zu viele Pflegebedürftige
Einweisung wir haben ja gemessen an der
Bevölkerung haben wir eine höhere
pflegedichte als unsere Nachbarländer es
gibt mehr Pflegekräfte auch im Beruf
also nicht nur ausgebildet aber nicht
mehr im Beruf sondern es gibt mehr
Pflegekräfte im Beruf
auf 100.000 Einwohner Alsbach in den
Nachbarländer trotzdem haben wir die
Verknappung was ist das Problem naja wir
haben 50% mehr
stationäre Krankenhauseinweisungen und
daher wird oft die Pflegekraft in der
Nacht eingesetzt um den stationären
Patienten dort zu betreuen
Schichtdienste in der Pflege oft nicht
belebt Schichtdienste dann eben
stationäre Verläufe die lange dauern und
das wollen wir verändern weil viele
dieser
Krankenhauseinweisungen könnten auch so
gemacht werden dass der Patient über Tag
behandelt wird dann wieder nach Hause
geht und dann wieder über Tag behandelt
wird die sogenannten
tagesfälle tagespfahlpauschalen und das
werden wir jetzt einführen da ist ein
Gesetz in Vorbereitung auch auf
Initiative der Regierungskommission
Krankenhaus das würde unmittelbar in der
Pflege eine Entlastung bringen denn
damit könnten wir sehr viele
Pflegekräfte freisetzen die jetzt diese
schwierigen auch langen Nachtdienste
machen müssen daran arbeiten wir
intensiv
sie schon eine ganze Menge Themen ich
rechne mit weiteren Besuchen der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach und auch ganz herzlichen Dank
an Margarete Stokowski es gibt noch die
Möglichkeit im Atrium Fotos zu machen
wenn sie herzlichen Dank